- But it was an unexpected kind of hazard
of that job, right.
- So you're in a small confined space.
The ring is 20 feet by 20 feet.
And you're with a group of guys
so you always want to
try to smell your best.
But here's the thing, we are
a global touring company.
So we'll do a show in Shanghai
and then come back to San Francisco,
and do a show in San Francisco.
And a lot of times,
and you know this from
being a touring musician,
sometimes travel gets messed up.
Sometimes flights get
delayed, so you can like--
- [Kelly] No sleep.
- Connect in Budapest,
land in San Francisco
and have to go to the ring in two minutes.
So everybody's given a few mulligans
in the B.O. and the breath category
but we also have a nice
form of policing ourselves
where somebody has a few more
mulligans than they should,
we kind of give them the old,
"Hey man, it's our office out
there. Could you kind of--"
- Keep it together.
- Yes exactly, exactly, exactly.
- So was your smell kind
of a secret strategy?
Did you ever smell on purpose
just to throw people off?
Give 'em the armpit kind of thing.
- Actually, that's a decent...
All these years I've been
punching my way out of trouble
when I could've just smelled really bad.
- [Kelly] Could've used B.O.
- Man, where were you?
No, my thing was always Tic-Tacs.
It's a nervous superstition
that I always have before
we go on a broadcast.
And I've had to ween myself off of them
'cause I would up to them
like three boxes a day.
And it's right in the 20
minutes before broadcast.
- (gasps) That's like a child.
- Yeah, it's pretty much 10,000
calories in straight sugar.
- Oh my gosh, and you know what,
you probably don't gain
a pound, do you John?
- Well, I have to go out there
and get beat up as you saw by the photo,
I don't really do well.
- Okay, you've taught me something.
I need to go get beat up
instead of working out.